j écoutais aujourd'hui je trouve sur
appuyez-vous sur le bouton c'est un
petit peu comme ce qu'on a fait la
dernière fois
préférez-vous ça ou ça sauf que là c'est
particulier et on a une affirmation mais
on a une autre affirmation est ce qu'on
accepte quand même ce que je veux dire
ça veut rien dire bon comment vous allez
comprendre et une par exemple tu deviens
un jedi
donc tu as tu maîtrises la force tu as
un sabre laser etc tout est inclus met
au village natal se fait attaquer par
des storm trooper et tes parents meurent
franchement être à djeddah il s'écoule
un plus de tests mes parents elle
j'appuie sur le bouton c phosphore 42%
des jantes sur et leurs parents pour est
à djerba et à la violence
deuxième dilemme bah voilà c'est tout
simplement des dilemmes à les smarties
tu as de la nourriture gratuite jusqu'à
la fin de ta vie mais tu perds tout est
d'en bas autant continuer à payer ma
bouffe comme 100 % des gens donc non
j'appuie paille à 25 % des gens qui me
veulent perdre leur temps quand même
pour pouvoir bouger alors finir bus tu
perds tes dents tu peux plus manger
c'est complètement con tu peux avoir
n'importe quel super pouvoirs attends ça
a l'air intéressant mais si quelqu'un te
vois les utiliser tu meurt
instantanément à séduire sa part ahmed
anthony pouvoir que choisit choisi la
visibilité donc même si je fais voler
par exemple ce pécule par télékinésie tu
vois un mec je suis visible donc tu veux
pas rare que c'est moi donc je meure
jamais d'y être est mort deux fois coeur
à ses piles 50/50 thuram et si quelqu'un
me vois me mettre invisible aa c'est là
qu'il faut que je fasse attention une
question seulement pour les mecs tu peux
devenir une fille extrêmement canon à
n'importe quel moment
béthune tribut sur tes propres pieds
presque tout le temps non based avec 49
% de gens veulent devenir une mode quand
même c'est évident parce que vous pouvez
même pas lui faire l'amour à cette fille
c'est tu deviens cette fille ça n'a pas
de sens tu es béni des dieux et à une
chance incroyable mais attachant s'est
inversée un jour par mois assez chaud
puis si ma chance est inversée je peux
me prendre un pot de fleur sur la tête
et mourir dans d'atroces souffrances du
coup dans tu contrôles le monde dans un
bureau dans l'espace avec le pouvoir de
voir tout ce qui se passe sur terre mais
tu ne quittera plus jamais ton bureau au
nord de kout est coincé tu vois tout ce
qui se passe mais tu est coincés comme
ça bah ouais mais bon on pourrait sauver
la planète depuis d'autres bureaux on
pourrait obliger les profs ahmed et 20
sur 20 à tout le monde
on pourrait mettre fin aux guerres on
pourrait mettre fin aux meurtres on
pourrait
on pourrait obliger le port de jupes
très très courtes aux filles aux la
terre arrive à prendre contact avec des
aliens
mais les aliens nous sommes un héros et
tueront tous les humains quoi pas le
mieux c'est de ne pas découvrir les à
l'aide à ce moment là quel est l'intérêt
nathan ya pas des gens qui ont bien
qu'ils ont pressé le bouton que 19% ont
pressé le bouton c'est à dire ils
veulent juste ward aliens faire ou un
alien l'apa sens tu as une source
illimité nourriture et en plus tu es le
seul à pouvoir les manger mais chaque
bouchée la nourriture aura le goût d'eau
sera pas de goût quoi je préfère payer
ma nourriture ne pas en avoir de manière
illimitée et garder ce corps ne lâche 61
% des gens à tomber sa muse et l'égoïsme
aulas moi je vais aller dans mon bureau
dans l'espace et je m'ai tué tous les
égoïstes à ça continue toute évaluation
et contrôle seront annulés pour le reste
de ta vie oh mais tu devrais étudié pour
cette évaluation qui n'arriveront jamais
jusqu'à la fin de ta vie mais c'est dès
l'automne étude fevad il ya des dilemmes
complètement con que tu es un test à
l'arrivée ou passes étaient obligés
d'étudier bas autant qu' un test pour
ensuite passer à autre chose a refait le
monde 1 dans ce petit bureau tu deviens
un acteur ou une actrice incroyable mais
tu dois être comme leonardo dicaprio est
gagnée au cas d'oscar havage de longue
taille calais j'appuie sur le bouton -
ben voilà à 80% des jo ont appuyé le
regarder dicaprio sauf si la paye des
oscars qu'il est de vie de merde
bon peut-être tu a anéanti le bowling et
le boul ax et le harcèlement moral et au
physique mais les gens bizarres ne sont
plus bizarre ils deviennent des gens
ennuyant des gens normaux et j'appuie
absolument pas voilà les gens bizarres
faty sow estimé comme des gens bizarres
n'ont pas suivi la basse à faire comme
tout le monde et donc être normaux pour
ne plus faire boule aiea les boues
rouges à pippa beach 50% des gens
appuyait maison rien compris faut juste
que ce qui embête les autres comprennent
que c'est pas parce que les autres sont
différents qu'il faut les faire chier
squeeze précédent c'est faux je me
présenterai aux élections municipales
mais de la piscine municipale pourrait
peut-être d'al jarreau nul avoir des
super bottes et de vie sociale mais
d'anvers seulement trois heures par nuit
je pense que tu peux dormir au moins
sept heures par nuit en ayant un peu de
vie sociale et des bonnes notes
bon sauf quand en prépa et fait des
études de malades d'ailleurs ceux qui
sont en prépa s'ils volent des bonnes
notes et une vie sociale c'est ce qu'il
faut il donc trois heures par nuit donc
dont j'ai pu passer c'est déjà le cas la
seule guillou c'est que ça tu fais
absolument tout ce que tu veux mais à
chaque fois que tu fais ce que tu veux
quelqu'un que tu es mort mais je plus
pas combien d'égoïsme 20% d'égoïste vais
dans mon bureau dans l'espace vous allez
voir tout ce que tu dessines se
matérialise dans la vraie vie et tu
obtiens les capacités destinées d'un
demi dieu mais un assassin tuable
tu es les créateurs de tous les jeux
vidéo que tu aimes pas je décide un
piège que je mets dans les studios des
créateurs de mon jeu préféré et quand
l'assassin ce point de bam il se
retrouve enfermé alors on peut pas le
tuer mais par contre il est bloqué dans
sa petite cage jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
oui tu peux faire en sorte que n'importe
qui t'aime mais n'importe qui peut faire
en sorte que tu lèves aussi ah non non
non non non non je préfère rester maître
de mes sentiments vraiment eu à la
capacité de voir l'avenir mais tu peux
pas le changer
voilà bah autant dans le futur et se
préparer soi même et ses proches en
fonction d'eux s'est par exemple il ya
une attaque nucléaire sur la france est
bien anticipé tu pars en russie la
russie aussi va se prendre une bombe
nucléaire se passe maintenant il faut
aller en bus au milieu de la mer tu peux
faire l'amour avec les filles que tu
veux juste en leur demandant mais attend
le mais va être terrible je pense que
c'est un truc de fou mais tu dois
regarder the notebook avant chaque
rapport sexuel the notebook c'est un
film sentimental fin de l'histoire
d'amour ces deux personnes qui font
l'amour puis bref ils font chacun leur
vie puis se retrouve plus tard et là
c'est le coup de foudre bref moi
j'appuie pas tu deviens instantanément
un super musicien tu peux jouer de
n'importe quel instrument mais tu as
toujours une musique dans la tête même
quand tu te concentres assas horrible ça
non j'appuie pas j'appuie pas 60% des
gens appuyé quand même un [ __ ] je
serai tout susciter au bout de trois
semaines c'est sûr tu seras capable de
voler mais tes jambes seront paralysés
bassma tagada dans les jambes paralysées
si tu peux voler puisque du coup tu peux
te déplacer au ras du sol et ça fait
comme si tu marches et ses théories de
merde ou pas ça semble correct je
pourrai plus faire ça non c'est mort sa
mort doit on en aura pu faire tu peux
avoir tous les supers pouvoirs que tu
veux mais tu ne pourras plus jamais
utilisé internet à je peux plus faire de
vidéos [ __ ] je m'en bats les couilles
de vous à les balancer pouvoir je vais
plus avec black drôle là ça me tue au
but ce n'est pas drôle tu as la capacité
de te téléporter une fois par jour mais
tu peux pas choisir vous tue téléporte
attend ses chevaux gars autant pas
prendre le risque de se téléporter c'est
débile
nous aussi on veut téléporter c'est pour
aller d'un point a à un point b
rapidement ce n'est pas pour aller d'un
point a à un point inconnus ou laborde
attend certainement 45 % des gens
accèdent bateau mais souffre où tu vas
te retrouver dans le tunnel sous la
manche avec un eurostar qui arrive face
à toi comme ça faut tourner dans le
temps libéré tous les juifs avant qu'ils
se fassent tuer à la seconde guerre
mondiale mais on ne fout dans une
chambre à gaz à tort aux [ __ ] ouais
mais bon tu sauves des millions de
personnes j'ai accepté une condition je
met un doigt dans le cul à hitler juste
avant et ensuite je fais sentir mon
doigt dans l'oeil
ces boutons ne me comme un citron on est
obligé c'est une mort pour des millions
d'innocents sauver un jeu presque 50% ne
presse pas
tu peux comprendre toutes les langues du
monde mais tu n'arrives pas à aller
parler ah non ça vient je peux pas
parler français non plus si tu me
laisses par les français mais samba
agen qui me répond mais peut pas me
répondre c'est débile tu deviens site
mais tu dois te fais ton meilleur pote
pour le devenir mais car tous ces
moments passés un jour sans tu sais je
pourrais jamais faire ça bien que tu me
batte sur les neuf dixièmes des jeux
outils louche ou banon banon mais je
deviens cité je te coupe la gorge batère
taka pas battre aux jeux vidéo oui bon
les gens c'est bien fin de cette vidéo
sur appuyez-vous sur le bouton puis ce
passionné a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas les mêmes vidéos cas d'habitude va
écouter c'est le deuxième petit jeu
qu'on fait comme ça aux voix un petit
peu l'opinion de chacun ça me fait
marrer à l'eau sont interdits prochaine
vidéo faire savoir regarder portez vous
bien c'est tout le monde pis